hi I'm Eric Davis we are here at South
by Southwest with the team from hearts
beat loud' director brett haley star
nick offerman welcome to our little
campfire thank you thank you yes we will
it's nice out here not not too many bugs
so Bret you know with I see you with my
dreams in the hero and now hard to be
loud I feel like there's a bit of a
trend with these aging artists who are
sort of rediscovering passion for their
craft for their lives what is it about
that theme that is so attractive to you
I mean to me more than it is you know
aging artists or anything like that I
think all of my movies are about shifts
big changes either coming up or have
have happened in people's lives because
I think that's what really defines a
life has change that we cannot control
you know so I'll see you in my dreams is
about loss it's about how we can't
control that will lose people that we
love and how to deal with that and the
hero is about one's legacy you know
getting a bad diagnosis and how to deal
with that and how to wrestle with one's
mortality and then this film is very
much about letting go and and and and
having to not only let go of one's own
personal dreams or aspirations but also
you know the reality of sending a
daughter or a child off to school to go
be an adult to leave the nest if you
will these are changes that every human
being on planet is going to you know
encounter in some way shape or form so I
try to make movies that I think everyone
can relate to on a really human and
honest level that's the goal anyway you
know I I can't imagine it's the easiest
task or maybe it is to find a father and
a daughter duo that are going to perform
and and have chemistry and so you know
how did that search go did you always
have have Nick and Kirstie in mind the
role was written for Nick so Frank is
Frank Fisher is it was written with Nick
Offerman in mind
it was the kind of role that my
co-writer mark Bosch and I wanted to see
Nick do we worked with him on our last
film the hero and we knew that this
movie was for him and finding Sam which
is what Keirsey ended up coming on to
play was a much more difficult and long
process I the only thing that I knew is
that I wanted the person to be of mixed
race I wanted a biracial family and in
the film and basically it was a process
of finding a person who could act who
could sing I was looking at all races
that's at one point basically and just
trying to find like how to do that and
once Keirsey I knew was available and
and I found out that Kirstie could sing
I knew she could act but when I heard
her sing I was like we're making an
offer today and everyone just get behind
me trust me I've got a feeling about
this we went for it and I think that one
of the great things about Keirsey is
that I leaned on her to inform that
character from her own personal
experiences from her life and I really
leaned on her so not only can Keirsey
act incredible singing credible she was
a huge asset to the truth of her
experience of her characters experience
because coming from her I I tried to
listen and interpret what her truth was
and I think that's a really powerful
thing so she brought even more to the
movie than just her talents yeah I was
watching this film and the music is just
so good and like though I I ended and I
said Nick are you two gonna go on tour
like are you gonna perform live I just
felt like I wanted to see more of you
too I felt like there was just that
chemistry there and sort of how did you
develop that how did you develop that
sort of father-daughter bond but also
this kind of you know artist bond as
well well first I just want to say when
when Brett and the producers had to find
who was going to play my daughter they
they took a close-up of my face and they
said we need to find a voice
that is commensurate with this and we
listen to a lot of singing Katy Perry
I know dice Janelle Monae was rejected
we landed on I'm cursing the the first
part of my answer to your question would
be all the credit has to go to Keegan
DeWitt who wrote the music and he and
his writing partner Jeremy Bulloch
taught us to play the music you know
really accuracy and I both play music
but not that music of that quality and
the combination of of their original
music and Bret's direction and
filmmaking acumen turned us into
superheroes you know so I mean Kier
she's amazing and so from the moment we
met we just immediately developed a
friendship that had you know because of
our ages it had those qualities of like
I you know would ask her if what I was
texting was hip or not and I've learned
that even my choice of the word hip was
wrong but I mean and so we had a real
father-daughter dynamic even in our
friendship of like older male friend
trying to you know make friends with
younger female friend and then and then
you know the scenes are just great you
know it's so much of it is in the script
and getting to screw around with you
know again to continue the superheroine
analogy we had these montages of sort
sort of these origin story montages of
like all I had to do was competently
play one one beat on a drum set but
because of the beautiful editing and the
incredibly invigorating sound suddenly
you know we look like the who so I'm I
was very grateful to be a vessel for the
talent
how did you play live on set a taller I
got a how did that work yeah we did we
did it mix all the vocals in the film or
live and there are just certain
challenges with recording music and
vocals with editing and multiple cameras
and multiple takes that you can't do
everything live all the time even though
I really wanted to everyone was like
well that's not possible so pick one or
you know pick one kind of thing and
really what was most important to me
were the vocals and hearing Nick and
Kirstie voice on the day so it felt real
and in the moment and didn't feel like a
music video or something like that so we
figured out a system you know systems
that like bigger big musicals like lame
is did it and la-la-land and for a few
scenes did it to where it's like you
know there are systems to get live
vocals on the day and get it with you
know mic like this and the mic that
she's holding or you know Nick just
singing in the room kind of a thing but
Nick Nick has the scene in the film
where he's playing acoustic guitar and
singing and that's all one take real on
the day as authentic as it can be so I
think it's flawless emotionally speaking
it might not be musically speaking but
that's that's who his character is in
that you know at that moment especially
what he's revealing to his daughter the
emotion it's all very it's a big scene
it's a big emotional scene so I really
love it and if there are mistakes their
purpose yep they're all come from my
classical training and what do you hope
audiences take away from this film I
don't know for me I mean it's just an
old-fashioned great movie about people
dealing with you know selfish hardships
and personal issues and having to choose
love in the end and so the movies really
funny it's got a lot of incredible
actors in it but ultimately I just find
it really moving
you know I'm probably more of a SAP than
I come across as and I love movies like
this that make me cry because the people
love each other you know in the end they
choose love yeah yeah absolutely
and I think I think the thing about this
movie especially right now it it this is
a true independent film and I think it
it feels that way and the best in the
best way but I think that it makes
people feel good it reminds them of the
small pleasures in their life and and
and I think the small pleasures are the
people around them that echoing what
Nick said that loved them and that they
loved and to just be reminded of that in
an honest and down-to-earth and
thoughtful way and the music is
seriously kick-ass people are gonna walk
out humming that tune oh yeah no I loved
it and when you intercede ooh go on tour
please invite us yeah done yes
absolutely thank you so much guys and
good luck with the film Thank You
ppreciate
[Music]
you
[Music]